[Music]
i want them to stick to their mission
statement about inclusion and equity and
in being there for the athletes we're
trying to grow a sport be inclusive and
you're telling me that
i
i'm literally being excluded because of
my disability i grew up in baton rouge
louisiana as a competitive gymnast and
my gymnastics career ended when i was
diagnosed with osteosarcoma bone cancer
and i had two options it was either let
cancer get the best of my life or move
on and find something that made me happy
i chose snowboarding because it reminded
me of a balance beam and if i could have
any piece of my old life back
i would have done anything to do it i do
not have a knee or a foot
not having a knee is massive in
snowboarding i competed in the 2018
paralympic games where i won two gold
medals so paralympic snowboarding is set
up in two different leg impairment
groups so you have ll1 which is the most
impaired leg disability group and then
you have ll2 which is the less impaired
disability group i currently compete in
ll1 and i competed in l01 at the korea
games
and back in 2019
the international paralympic committee
made the decision to not include
ll-1 women in the paralympics however
we were told that we could compete
in the ll2 group with the less disabled
athletes
even though we would be at a
disadvantage we were still offered that
opportunity to compete and in february
of 2021
the qualification guides came out we
were completely excluded from the
qualification guide and the program in
china
so they eliminated our category of
competition because we didn't have
enough participants i mean immediately
when we found out that we could not
compete um there was actually a rule
that said if there is less than three
women in the ll1 class they can compete
with the ll2 women so the more disabled
women competed with the less impaired
women and
in our competitions both myself and my
competitor at one event one first and
second there is no language in our
rulebook that says we can compete but
there is also no language in our
rulebook that says we cannot compete i'm
very hopeful that this can happen
because the reasoning for me to not
compete
it's not big enough it doesn't make any
sense i want the opportunity to defend
my gold medals i know given that
opportunity i can do it and i'm not
going to stop fighting
you